[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في حصاد الليله معكم
حسن جمو وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع
احداث وتتفاعل اخرى والبدايه من الخرطوم
والاعلان عن مهله مدتها خمسه ايام لحل
القضايا التي تحول دون التوقيع على
الاتفاق النهائي للعمليه السياسيه في
السودان
والى موسكو حيث وعد وزير الدفاع بزياده
امدادات الذخيره للقوات الروسيه وذلك قبل
هجوم مضاد مرتقب للقوات الاوكرانيه
ونختتم جوله صور المباشره من هيلسينكي
عشيه تصويت الفنلنديين في الانتخابات
العامه التي تجرى على وقع تراجع اقتصادي
وبعد تغييرات هي الاكبر في السياسه
الخارجيه للبلاد منذ عقود
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
[موسيقى]
اصابه ثلاثه جنود اسرائيليين في عمليه دهس
في منطقه بيت ام مارشال الخليل وقوات
الاحتلال تقول انها قتلت سائق المركبه
بعد اجتماع استمر ساعات في قصر الرئاسه
بالخرطوم الاطراف المدنيه والعسكريه تتفق
على تاجيل توقيع الاتفاق النهائي بالعمليه
السياسيه الى السادس من ابريل وسط خلافات
يتصدرها دمج قوات الدعم السريع في الجيش
السوداني
تزامنا مع معارك على جبهات الاوكرانيه عده
وزير الدفاع الروسي يعد بزياده امدادات
الذخيره لقوات بلاده بعد ايام من انتقادات
حاده من رئيس مجموعه فاجنر وقبل هجوم
الربيع المضاد كياف تترقب الاعلان عن حزمه
مساعدات عسكريه امريكيه جديده بقيمه اكثر
من مليار دولار تتضمن سته انواع من
الذخائر
قبل مثوله المرتقب امام المحكمه الثلاثاء
فريق ترامب القانوني يفكر بطلب نقل قضيه
الرئيس الامريكي السابق من منهاتن ومصادر
تقول ان لائحه الاتهام تتضمن توهمًا عديدا
من بينها تزوير سجلات تجاريه وجنايه واحده
على الاقل
مشاهدينا في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على
منصاتنا الرقميه
ناقشنا مسارات الازمه في السودان بعد
اعلان المتحدث باسم العمليه السياسيه
تاجيل التوقيع على الاتفاق النهائي الى
يوم السادس من ابريل الحالي بدلا من اليوم
وذلك بسبب عدم التوافق على قضايا عالقه
لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد
طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي
برايكم ما هي سيناريوهات الازمه السياسيه
في السودان اجاباتكم جاءت على النحو
التالي نحو 26% توقعوا تسويه الخلافات قبل
الخميس المقبل بينما قال 74% ان مزيدا من
الخلافات ستعرقل التوقيع
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
من مسستي وكانتاكي وتنسى وجورجيا عصير
تتسبب بسقوط قتلى في الولايات المتحده
وحرمان مئات الاف الاسر من الكهرباء
[موسيقى]
البدايه اذا من الاراضي الفلسطينيه والخبر
العاجل حيث اكدت مصادر اسرائيليه ان جنود
الاحتلال قتلوا رميا بالرصاص سائق سياره
فلسطينيه بعد تنفيذه عمليه دهس استهدفت
عددا من الجنود عندما مدخل بلده بيت شمال
مدينه الخليل بالضفه الغربيه المحتله
وافادت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه ان ثلاثه
جنود اصيب بجراحه جراء تعرضهم للدهس بينما
اكدت القناه الاسرائيليه الثانيه عشره ان
الجنود قتلوا سائق السياره
للمزيد من التفاصيل ينضم الينا من رام
الله مراسل الجزيره سمير ابو شمل سمير اخر
المعلومات حول عمليه الداسيات
نعم حسن بدايه هيئه الشؤون المدنيه
الفلسطينيه ابلغت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه
باستشهاد الشاب محمد برادعي البالغ من
العمر 24 عاما في عمليه بيت امر هذه ليله
شمالي مدينه الخليل وهو يعمل ضابط في جهاز
الامن الوطني التابع للسلطه الفلسطينيه
ووالده ايضا مقدم يعمل برتبه مقدم في جهاز
الخدمات الطبيه
العسكريه الاذاعه الجيش الاسرائيليه قالت
بان وحتى بيان الجيش المقتضب الذي تحدث عن
هذه العمليه بان الشاب كان يستقل هذه
السياره وقد توجه على باتجاه مجموعه من
الجنود الاسرائيليين الذين كانوا يعملون
لتامين الطريق الواصل بين مخيم العروبه
بيت ام شمالي مدينه الخليل والقريبه من
تجمع غوشك غوش
البريطانيه وقد توجهت هذه السياره ودهست
ثلاثه جنود اسرائيل حيث اصيبوا بجروح وصفت
الثاني منهم اثنين منهم بالخطيره والاخوه
والثالثه بالمتوسطه وقد تم نقلهم الى
مستشفيات هداسه عين كارم وايضا في مدينه
القدس الغربيه والاصابات هي بالكدمات
بالظهر والبطن وايضا باطراف هذا ما جاء
على ابي لسان المتحدث باسم جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه
دفعت بتعزيزات اضافيه عسكريه الى محيط
مكان العمليه وقد خلق ذلك عزبه خانقه
للمركبات والفلسطينيين المتوجهين الى
مدينه الخليل وايضا الخارجين منها وايضا
في هذه الاثناء هناك عمليه هدوء وحاله
هدوء مستقره في تلك المنطقه بعد ساعات على
تنفيذ حادثه حسب بيان جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيليه في بلده بيت ام هناك مواجهات
قد وقعت في القصيده في داخل البلده عقب
هذه العمليه بين شبان البلده والجيش
الاحتلال الذي استخدم قنابل الغاز المسيل
للدموع واطلقها على منازل المواطنين مما
ادى الى اصابه العشرات بالاختراق بالغاز
المسيل لدموع ردود الفعل الفصائليه
الفلسطينيه قد باركت هذه العمليه واكلت
بانها تاتي في سياق الرد الطبيعي على
جرائم الاحتلال ومستوطنين والتي كان اخرها
قتل الطبيب محمد العصيبي يوم امس عند باب
السلسله في داخل البلده القديمه والمؤدي
الى المسجد الاقصى المبارك برصاص الجنود
وشرطه الاحتلال الاسرائيليه سمير ابو
شناله مراسل الجزيره من رام الله شكرا
جزيلا لك
مشهد التصيد في الضفه الغربيه يرافقها
مازق متصاعد تواجه حكومه نتنياهو حيث
يواصل عشرات الالاف من انصار المعرضه
التظاهر في عده مدن للاسبوع الثالث عشر
على التوالي احتجاجا على مشروع التعديلات
القضائيه التي تتبناه حكومه اليمين
بقيادته واحتشد اكثر من 175 الفا في تل
ابيب رافعين الاعلام الاسرائيلي وشعارات
مناهضه لنتنياهو والمتحلفين معهم من
اليمين المتطرف في محاوله لتجفيف الضغط
على الائتلاف الحكومي حتى بعد اعلان
نتنياهو الاثنين الماضي تجميد المشروع
والدخول في مفاوضات مع المعارضه كما شهدت
المظاهرات لاول مره رفع اعلام امريكيه بعد
موقف الاداره الامريكيه الذي اعتبر ضغطا
على نتنياهو
[موسيقى]
شددت اطراف العمليات السياسيه في السودان
على ضروره حسم الخلافات بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع بشان الدمج
والتسريح في مده اقصاها اسبوع وقال الناطق
باسم العمليه السياسيه خالد عمر ان اتفاقا
وقع في ال 15 من مارس يشكل مرجعيه لحسم
الخلافات بين اطراف المكون العسكري وقد
حال الخلاف بين الجانبين الى عدم توقيع
الاتفاق السياسي النهائي الذي كان مقررا
اليوم
مهله جديده مدتها خمسه ايام لاعطي مجال
لحسم الخلافات التي ظهرت بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع قبل توقيع
الاتفاق السياسي النهائي في السادس من
ابريل الحالي دمج قوات الدعم السريع في
الجيش نقطه الخلاف الابرز بين الجانبين
الناطق باسم العمليه السياسيه خالد عمر
قال ان مساله الدمج تجري وفق مرجعيات متفق
عليها قرات الاطراف الحاضر بالاجبار
العسكريه
ان تكثف من جهدها لحل هذه القضايا الفنيه
العالقه خلال الفتره من الليله وحتى يوم
السادس من ابريل الخلافات بين الجيش
والدعم السريع ترتكز حول المده الزمنيه
للدمج يرى الجيش ان ذلك ينبغي ان يكون
خلال الفتره الانتقاليه بينما تقترح قوات
الدعم الضعاف لمده التي تحدث عنها الجيش
وترى تلك القوات ضروره اجراء اصلاحات
شامله للاجهزه الامنيه قبل دمجها بينما
يرى الجيش ان قضيه الاصلاح شان يخص القوات
المسلحه معضله الاساسيه كيف سيتم استيعاب
وتسريح ونزع بعض الجنود الذين يتبعون
لقوات الدعم السري لان هذه القوات أذاع
الطبيعه عشائريه وتحالفاتها تحالفات
اقليميه مما يصعب هذا الامر وفي الوقت
الذي تتسارع فيه الخطه لمعالجه قضيه دمج
قوات الدعم السريعه تكثف لجنه الوسطاء
اتصالاتها لاقناع الرافدين بالانضمام الى
العمليه السياسيه لكنها جهود لم تؤتي
اكلها حتى الان نحن موقفنا هو النصل الى
اتفاق سياسي جديد
وهذا الاتفاق هو الذي يؤدي الى انهاء هذه
الازمه السياسيه
والوصول الى التوافق المعقول الذي يضمن
لنا الاستقرار السياسي والاقتصادي والامني
في البلاد وقد اغلقها منسوبون الى المجلس
الاعلى للنظرات البيئه الطريق القوميه
الرابطه بين مدينه بورسودان الخرطوم لمده
يوم واحد عند نقطه سين كات وقاموا باشعال
الاطارات ووضع الحواجز الترابيه احتياجا
على سير العمليه السياسيه
مهله جديده لتوقيع الاتفاق السياسي
النهائي وحل ازمه مستعصيه بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع ازمه ذات التشعبات سياسيه
باتت تشكل هاجسا لدى كثيرين ما يهدد
العمليه السياسيه برومتها الطاهره المرضي
الجزيره الخرطوم
ينضم الينا من الخرطوم شهاب ابراهيم
المتحدث باسم الحريه والتغيير المجلس
المركزي ومن الخرطوم ايضا ينضم الينا
مبارك اردول القيادي بقوه الحريه والتغيير
الكتله الديمقراطيه سابدا معك سيد شهاب
ابراهيم ومهله
الاسبوع يعني حتى السادس من ابريل الجاري
هل هي مهله واقعيه
للتواصل الجانبين الجيش والدعم السريع
لاتفاق حول مساله الدمج
طيب السلام عليكم ورحمه الله عليكم اولا
خلينا ننطلق من فرضيه انه ما تبقى في قضيه
الاصلاح الامني والعسكري هي قضيتين هي
القضيه الاولى متعلقه
الجداول الزمنيه الخاصه بدمج الدعم السريع
والمده الزمنيه التي سيتم فيها هذا الدمج
الشيعي الثاني اللي هو توحيد قياده
في والسيطره في الفتره القادمه وفي
احتفادنا انه القضيتين هما هنالك تصورات
اصلا مطروحه من الجانبين بالتالي
لا يمكن ان نتعامل معها الان في في في في
في يعني بالتحديد في هذا القضيتين
كقضيتين سياسيتين بقدر ما هي قضايا فنيه
يجب ان تحسمها
يحسمها الطرفين العسكريين لانها هي دي من
صميم القضايا الفنيه
رمضان كريم
وتحيه لكل المشاهدين
بالحقيقه يعني هؤلاء الزملاء ادخلوا
انفسهم في نفق ليس من السهل الخروج منه
هذه القضيه قضيه معاقده وشائكه للغايه
ليست من مهام قضايا الانتقال من الاساس
يعني
ما كان صحيح انه يطرح هذا الامر في هذا
الوقت تحديدا
قضيه دمج
القوات وخروج بجيش وطني واحد يعني يتطلب
يعني شروط موضوعيه مثلي ومثل ضيفك الكريم
عندما نتحدث عن هذا الامر يجب ان نستمد
قوتنا من الشعب ويجب ان نكونوا منتخبين في
برلمان منتخب من الشعب لكل لدينا شرعيه
ومن ثم اعضاء فلجنه الامن والدفاع ومن ثم
يمكننا ان نستدعي قاده الجيوش ويمكننا ان
نضع المصفوفات ونحن مستبدين قوتنا من ذلك
المكان المشكله التي يواجهها هؤلاء يرون
انفسهم يمكنهم
بمجرد يعني جلوسهم مع العسكري يمكن ان
يؤثروا او يغيروا في شكل الدوله خلال فتره
الانتقال وهو ما قد اصطدموا به الان هذه
القضيه لا يمكن ان تحلل الان بالنسبه لنا
نراها هذه القضايا يجب ان تكون قضايا مع
بعض المرحله الانتقاليه وهي قضيه يعني
يعني جوهريه تتعلق بصميم الدوله
وبهياكلها وتتعلق
بالقوات
وحتى تكون لدينا الصيغه والدافع القوي في
التحدث عن قضيه نعم هذه نقطه مهمه فعلا
السيد هؤلاء نعم واضح هذه النقطه مهمه جدا
سيد
شهاده ابراهيم فعلا هل هل يعقل ان تصبح
المرحله الانتقاليه والاتفاق السياسي
برمته
رهن اتفاق الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع يعني
اذا لم يتفق الجانبان ستتعطل المرحله
الانتقاليه وربما يتعطل معها كل الاتفاق
لماذا
رهن مستقبل العمليه السياسيه
باتفاق بين الدعم السريع والجيش
طبعا اولا خلينا ننظر ان احنا ما قبل 25
اكتوبر وخمسه وعشرين اكتوبر وجودها تعدد
هذه الجيوش
وواحد من المهددات التي قطعت الطريق امام
التحول المدني الديمقراطي ودمرت كل
المكتسبات التي حققتها ثوره ديسمبر ما بعد
اللي هو 11 ابريل الان هو
ان يكون هنالك جيش واحد ده مطلب
للثوره ومشروع التغيير في السودان اللي
انطلق من قبل اربع سنوات ان يكون هنالك
جيش واحد ومهني حقيقه الامر لم نستطع في
وجود تلك الشراكه المسمومه ان يتم هذا
الشيء لكن اعتقد انه الجيد ان يذكر في هذا
الاتفاق الاطار وواحد من النقاط المهمه ان
يتم تكوين او بدايه تكوين واحد نحن واعين
تماما انه عمليه الاصلاح الامني والعسكري
ودمج الجيوش هي ليست قضيه يمكن ان تتم في
الفتره الانتقاليه فقط لكن ان تبدا هذه
المساله ونبدا في ان تكون هنالك قياده
واحده تسيطر على القوات
جميع القوات هي دي واحد من النقاط
الايجابيه اللي يمكن ان تضمن على الاقل ان
نصل الى انتخاباته ومن ثم يكون هنالك
شرعيه نعم
عفوا ليس ليس ليس ان يبغى الامر سيدي انا
اتحدث لك هذه يمكن شرعيه القبول من من
الجماهيريه هي ليست جديده الان للحريه
والتغيير او غيرها من القوه السوداويه عن
الشرعيه الان نحن نتحدث نحن نتحدث عن
مشكله قائمه بين مكونين عسكريين ربما تطي
ح بكل العمليه السياسيه اذا لم يتفقا وهنا
سانتقل الى السيد اردوون للسؤال
هل ترى بان المشكله بين الجانبين اعمق
واعقد من مساله الفتره الزمنيه المطلوبه
للدمج وهو وهو الامر المعلن حتى اللحظه
نعم المشكله عقد نعم المشكله يعني في
طابعها امني ولكن لديها جوانب سياسيه نحن
بالنسبه لنا حكومه الانتقال يجب ان تستجيب
لقضايا محدده ويجب ان تعالج قضايا محدده
منها قضايا اليوم ومنها قضايا الازمه
الاقتصاديه ومنها التحضير للانتخابات
واكمال السلام وعوده النازحين والناجين
ولكن القضايا الكبرى مثل اعاده هيكله
القطاع الامني وغيرها من القضايا التي
تتعلق بالعلاقات الخارجيه وغيرها من
القضايا المعقده التي تتطلب شرعيه يجب ان
ترحل الى قضايا مع بعض الارتقال هذه
رؤيتنا في الكتله الديمقراطيه
والان يعني هؤلاء يعني ارادوا ان يتكسبوا
بقضايا وراوا ان من السهل يعني هذا
المعسكر كان موحدا من قبل قلنا لهم هذا
الاتفاق الذي وقعتموه سوف لن يوحدكم انتم
ولن يوحد العسكريين ولن يوحد الشارع ولن
يوحد الشعب السوداني الان بدات الظواهر
واضحه وبدات الازمه في تضب في معسكر من
وقع على الاتفاق الايطالي نفسهم قبل ان
نكون نحن في الان المخرج الوحيد للازمه
التي يعني واجهوها ان يجب ان يحول هذا
الامر يلغى هذا الامر تماما ينتقل الناس
لاتفاق اعلان سياسي جديد وهو المخرج
الاعلان السياسي يجب ان يؤسس لوضعيه جديده
خلال الانتقال مهام محدده للحكومه هذه
القضايا الخلافيه وهم جربوها الان ولن تحل
بهذه الطريقه يجب ان ترحل لما بعد
الانتقال وهي الرؤيه السليمه والواضحه غير
ذلك سوف تصطدم هذه المساله ولربما تقود
البلاد لازمات حربيه اذا كانت حرب اهليه
او او ما بين القوات المتحاربه نحن نريد
ما بين المعسكرات المختلفه جزيلا لك انتهى
وقتنا الكفاح
في قوى الحريه والتغيير الكتله
الديمقراطيه من الخرطوم وشكرا لشهاب
ابراهيم المتحدث باسم الحريه والتغيير
المجلس المركزي
[موسيقى]
الى تطورات الحرب في اوكرانيا فعلى وقع
معارك محتدمه هناك على جبهتي الشرق
والجنوب اعلن وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجيو
زياده امدادات الذخيره وانتاج الذخائر
عاليه الدقه لقوات بلاده في الحرب اما
واشنطن بالرغم من اتهام امبونسكو بالفشل
استراتيجيا وعمليا في تلك الحرب فقد
استبعد رئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيه
المشتركه الجنرال مارت ميلي نجاحك يا في
طرد القوات الروسيه خلال العام الحالي
قادمون من جهات اربع
ينسق الرسو هجماتهم في الشرق الاوكراني
على ليمون ومخمت ومارينكا
في وقت واحد لكن غايتهم الكبرى تبقى ضخمه
من الاهداف ذات الاولويه للعدو خلال هذا
اليوم تعرضت مناطقها لمئه وسبعين قذيفه
مدفعيه وصاروخيه عدد الهجمات في بخموت
انخفض بشكل طفيف ويجب ان تؤخذ في الاعتبار
عوامل عده معقده وظروف المناخ ومحاولات
اعاده تجميع قوات العدو
يقول الطرف الاوكراني ان الروس لا يحققون
اي تقدم يذكر على الجبهه الشرقيه ويقول
الشيء ذاته عن خرسون جنوبا حيث يستمر
القصف الروسي كثيفا على المقاطعه لن تشير
موسكو بالطبع الى ما يعترضها من عقبات
لتحقيق اهداف ما تسميها عمليتها العسكريه
الخاصه في اوكرانيا لكنها لا تخفي الحاجه
لتحسين كفاءه النظام اللوجستي لتزويد
قواتها بالضروري من الاسلحه والذخائر
تحققت خلال الاسبوع الجاري من استيفاء
مؤسسات المجمع الصناعي العسكري لانتاج
الذخائر التي طلبتها وزاره الدفاع ونظرا
لتوسيع القدرات الانتاجيه وزياده انتاجيه
العماله فقد زاد عدد المنتجات المصنعه من
قبلهم لدعم القوات مرات عده الحديث يدور
عن عده انواع من الاسلحه التقليديه وعاليه
الدقه تعرضت وزارته في الشهور الماضيه
لانتقادات حاده من اشد المدافعين عن الحرب
الروسيه في اوكرانيا لعدم توفير ذخيره
كافيه للقوات على خط المواجهه لكن زياده
امدادات الذخيره وانتاج الذخائر عاليه
الدقه قد يفسرها حلفائك باوقات عصيبه يمر
بها الروس في اوكرانيا
يقرا الامريكيون في ذلك وغيره من معطيات
الميدان فشل استراتيجيا وعمليا لموسكو لكن
الرئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيه المشتركه
يستدرك
الجنرال مارك مالي استبعد نجاح القوات
الاوكرانيه في طرد جميع القوات الروسيه من
اراضيها هذا العام ماذا بقي اذا لهجوم
الربيع المضاد الذي طالما لوح به
الاوكرانيون
يعتقد البانتاجون ان اخراج القوات الروسيه
من اوكرانيا مهمه عسكريه صعبه للغايه
لكنها ليست مستحيله اما ما قد يقتضيه
الامر من وجهه نظر امريكيه فضرب
الاوكرانيين مقر اسطول البحر الاسود
الروسي في شبه جزيره القرم تقول كييف ان
الاسطوله عزز تشكيل سفنه اخيرا مما يجعل
التهديد بتوجيه ضربه صاروخيه مرتفعا
للغايه
ينضم الينا من وسكلسن العقيد لينقولينز
المستشار السابق لوزير الدفاع الامريكي
لشؤون اوكرانيا كما ينضم الينا من موسكو
العقيد فيكتور لتوفكين محرر اشمون
العسكريه في وكاله تااس الروسيه معك سيد
فيكتور سابدا للسؤال عن العقبات الفعليه
التي تعترض تقدم القوات الروسيه في باخموت
وتباطؤ هذا الهجوم بشكل كبير وواضح
هنا يوجد مجموعه من الاسباب اولا ان
القوات الاوكرانيه تحتل مواقع
ومساحات
داخل المناطق السكانيه والقوات الروسيه
بشكل متعمد لا تقوم بهجمات ضد هذه المواقع
على عكس ما قامت به الولايات المتحده في
غوتلافيا
وكما قصفت العراق وقصافه سوريا
وليبيا وافغانستان نحن نحاول ان
نقلل الضرر اتجاه المدنيين السالمين ونقوم
بهجمات دقيقه جدا هذا صعب بالطبع يوجد
مقاومه قويه جدا من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه
خاصه انهم يحصلون على الشحاء وامدادات من
قبل نظام كيف انهم يستخدموهم كحطب نار
لذلك هذه المهمه صعبه جدا يجب نفهم اننا
ليسنا على عجل وليس لدينا هدف ان نحرر في
الشهر القادم او الذي بعده
المناطق نقوم باهدافنا خطوه بعد خطوه
لكننا ننجح بها ولكن يعني هناك ايضا شحفه
ذخيره اليس كذلك يعني هناك عدم امداد كافي
بالذخيره وهذا اصبح
منقولا على لسان رئيس مجموعه فاجنر
وباعتراف حتى وزير الدفاع الروسي
الذخيره دائما تكون شحيحه يجب ان نستخدمها
بطريقه عقلانيه دون
رش العدو بالذخيره يجب ان نقصف العدو بدقه
حتى يكون لدينا وفره واستخدام فعال
للذخيره وعدم ضياعها بحجم كبير
طيب سيد
يعني رغم هذه العقبات ورغم هذه الصعوبات
التي يعني من وقت لاخر يعترف بها الجانب
الروسي في هجومي على باق موت لكن في
المقابل
رئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيه لا يتوقع ان
تنجح القوات الاوكرانيه في استعاده
اراضيها خلال هذا العام
لماذا ما هي المعطيات التي استند اليها
برايك
هذا صحيح كما تفضل الجنرال
من غير المتوقع ان تعمل القوات الاوكرانيه
على استعاده معظم الاراضي هذا العام بدا
ضرر لتواجد اعداد كبيره من القوات الروسيه
على الاراضي الاوكرانيه وايضا استخدام
الكثير من الاسلحه في مناطق مختلفه وهناك
ادرار طبعا بيع بناء التحتيه عبر البلد
اعتقد ان الاوكرانيون لم يحققوا نجاحات
كبيره الى غايه الان وهناك وجود كبير
للقوات الروسيه في مختلف المدن لكن اعتقد
اننا سنتوقع هجمات مرتده وهجمات عكسيه من
قبل القوات الاوكرانيه في القريب العاجل
ولكن يعني ايضا كما ان هناك شح في
الذخيره لدى الجانب
الروسي هناك ايضا في المقابل شحفه الذخيره
لهجوميه اذا صح التعبير لدى الجانب
الاوكراني وهذا ربما ما يمنع من محاوله
التقدم او شنهجمات مضاده مباشره
نعم هذا صحيح من دون شك الطرفان يعانيان
من نقص في الذخيره لان هناك استنزاف كبير
للذخيره اذا ما امتدت الحرب لي فتره طويله
روسيا طبعا حضرت
لهذه الحرب منذ فتره طويله ولم تكن تتوقع
روسيا ايضا ان يكون هناك دعم من قبل الغرب
صمدت لفتره طويله بفضل امدادات الغرب
لاوكرانيا بالذخيره المطلوب ونعم الذخيره
تستنزف على الطرفين وهناك حاجه لاستمرار
انتاج وتزويد الجبهات بالذخيره
طيب
عندما تقول بانه
روسيا غير مستعجله غير مستعجله في ظل
استنفاد ذخيره واستنفاذ قدرات وايضا ربما
استفاد معنويات هل من مصلحه روسيا
ان تاخذ على جماد كل هذا الوقت وتستنفذ كل
هذه المخدرات العسكريه
يضم اعتقد ان لدى روسيا استعداد نفسي كافي
لدى الجنود للقيام بالمهمات المساله هنا
ما هي المهمات التي تضعها الاداره
العسكريه لروسيا عفوا الاداره السياسيه هل
نتقدم ام هل نبقى على
مواقعنا للدفاع بالنسبه للهجمات المرتده
الاوكرانيه ليس لدى اوكرانيا اوكرانيا
معدات عسكريه كافيه وليس لديهم طيران دون
طيران لن يستطيعوا ان يقوموا باي هجمات
عكسيه اي هجمات عكسيه دون طيران سوف تدمر
وتقهر تماما لذلك من المستبعد ان تستطيع
اوكرانيا انشاء هجمات عكسيه ضد روسيا
والسيد مارك ميلي يفهم هذا جيدا لذلك هو
يشكك في امكانيات اوكرانيا على تحري
المواقع الاوكرانيه التي تسمى روسيه في
الوقت الحالي سيد ليان طيب اذا اذا كان
مارك ميلي يعترف فعلا بان القوات
الاوكرانيه غير قادره على استعاده اراضيها
خلال هذا العام ما الذي يرتبه ذلك على
الولايات المتحده من مواقف لانه المواقف
السياسيه مرتبطه بما يتم تحقيقه ميدانيا
على الارض الفشل الاوكراني في مكان ما
ماذا يرتبه
نعم هذا صحيح نحن توقعنا ان تكون هذه
الحرب حربا طويله والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ستستمر في تقديمها الدعم لي
اوكرانيا سمعنا ما تحدث به ضيفنا في روسيا
نعم روسيا الان ايضا عانت بشكل كبير منذ
بدايه الحرب ولا اعتقد ان الامر سيتغير في
المرحله الراهنه الروس كانوا يعتقدون انهم
سيقومون بالسيطره على اوكرانيا في ايام
لكن الايام تحولت الى شهور بل وسنوات
العقيد لين كولينز المستشار السابق لوزير
الدفاع الامريكيه لشؤون اوكرانيا شكرا
جزيلا لك وشكرا للعقيد فيكتور
محرر شؤون العسكريه في وكاله تاس الروسيه
لاحقا مشاهدينا في فقره المتابعه نسلط
الضوء على امدادات الذخيره المرتقبه لطرفي
القتال في الجبهات الاوكرانيه ونسال خبيرا
عسكريا عن اهميه هذه الامدادات
[موسيقى]
في الولايات المتحده نقلت وكاله سوشيال عن
مصادر مطلعه قولها ان الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب يواجه تهمه جنائيه
واحده على الاقل في لائحه الاتهام التي
اقرتها هيئه محلفين في منهات واوضحت
الوكاله ان الرئيس السابق يواجه توهما
متعدده اخرى بتزوير سجلات تجاريه سيكشف
عنها عندما يسلم نفسه يوم الثلاثاء المقبل
واضافت ان ترامب سيتعرض للاحتجاز على
الاغلب كما يحدث لاي شخص يواجه تهاما
وستؤخذ بصماته ولكن لن يتم تقييد يديه كما
رجحت ان يتم اطلاق سراحه في اليوم ذاته
عن مصدر مطلع قوله ان فريق ترامب القانوني
يدرس طلب نقل قضيه الرئيس السابق الجنائيه
الى ستاتين ايليند وبحسب المصدر فان هذه
الخطوه تاتي بسبب مخاوف الفريق بان ترامب
لن يحصل على محاكمه عادله في منهج
ادوات تشهد ولايه نيويورك حاله استنفار
امني مشدده تمهيدا لمثول ترند امام
المحكمه الثلاثاء حيث يتوقع ان تتمه تلاوه
التهم الموجهه اليه على مسامعه واخذ
بصماته وصورته في اجراء لم يسبق لرئيس
امريكي سابق انخض عليه
بالموت والدمار سبق ان هدد الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب في حال تم
اعتقاله لكن سيناريو اعتقاله لا يبدو
واردا الا في حال رفض ترامب الاستسلام
والخضوع لطلب الحضور امام المحكمه وهو ما
يقول محاميه انه مستعد للامثال له وتمهيدا
للمتول امام الادعاء الثلاثاء المقبل سيصل
ترامب الى نيويورك قادما من فلوريدا علامه
طائرته الخاصه الاثنين على ان يقضي ليلته
في برجه في نيويورك ويتوجه بعدها ليواجه
متوهم به في اولى مراحل الادعاء حسب
مقربين منه تحدث لوكاله بلومبرج وتلقي هذه
الاجراءات بظلال من القلق على مدينه
نيويورك التي تتاهب للحدث فشرطتها المحليه
وشرطه الولايه ووكالات الفيدراليه مستنفره
امنيا تاهبا لما يمكن ان يرافق حضور ترامب
امام الادعاء من مظاهرات او اعمال عنف من
انصاره الذين دعاهم للاحتجاج دعما له
وانتزاع البلاد ممن يصفهم تر باليسار
الراديكالي اما الاجراءات المتوقع ان يخضع
الرئيس السابق لها لدى وصوله الى المحكمه
فهي قراءه التهم الموجهه اليه ثم اخذ
بصماته والتقاط صوره عرضيه وطوليه لملامحه
وهو ما لم يخضع له رئيس الامريكي قبله
ويواجه ترامب في هذه القضيه وحدها اكثر من
30 اتهاما حسب مصادر اطلعت على تفاصيلها
ويتوقع بعد ذلك ان يسمح له بالانصراف في
انتظار ان تبدا المحاكمه بعد اسابيع او
اشهر وهذا ان بدات المحاكمه اصلا حيث يجوز
للقاضي ان يصرف القضيه ان لم يقتنع
بمبررات الادعاء او امراه بان دوافعها
سياسيه ولا تقف مزاعمها على ارضيه صلبه
اما اذا اقتنع القاضي باسس القضيه فيمكن
بعدها ان تبدا المحاكمه التي قد تاخذ
اسابيعها واشهرا وعلى الادعاء فيها اثبات
ان ترامب خرق القانون عن قصد لاستصدار
الادانه والحكم عليه
استاذ الحكومه والقانون الدستوري في
الجامعه الامريكيه مرحبا بك سيدك هل هناك
سابقه
بان قاضيا صرف النظر عن قضيه لعدم
اقتناعه مطلقا بتهم الادعاء العام في
قضايا فيها جنائيه تحديدا
شكرا جزيلا على الاستضافه نعم بالتاكيد
هذا يحدث في غير ما مر واعتقد ان
دونا الان يواجه هذه التهمه
وبامكانه ايضا ان يدافع عن نفسها واذا ما
وجدت ادله فيمكن ان طبعا ان يصرف النظر عن
هذه القضيه هذا الشيء قد يحدث طبعا فريق
ترامب القانوني يدرس طلب هذه القضيه نقل
هذه القضيه الى ستن ايلاند لانه
يخشى محاكمه غير عادله في منهات لماذا
ستاتن ايلنت
احد الاماكن الخاصه
هناك بالكثير من الدعم السياسي
وطبعا لا يمكن تغيير ما كان نظر في القضيه
هكذا ينبغي ان يكون هناك سبب مقنع ولا
اعتقد ان الدعم
سيكون السبب ان مقنعا بالنسبه للقاضي من
اجل النقل النظر في القضيه الى تلك
المنطقه
القضاء هنا في قضيه من هذا النوع لها
ارتدادات سياسيه
وارتدادات كبرى في الشارع الامريكي هل
يمكن للقضاء ان يتاثر بتلك الانعكاسات
والارتدادات
لا اعتقد ذلك لا اتوقع ان تكون هناك
تاثيرات على القضاء لكن ما قد يحدث هو ان
نرى
يهاجم النظام القضائي وانا رايت الكثير من
التصريحات
لتامبو وقال
بان هناك من يتحكم في الادعاء العامه
واعتقد ان هذه التصريحات غير مقبوله على
الاطلاق وايضا هاجم القضاء بالتالي
ترامب هو الذي
يمس
بالقضاء واعتقد ان ما يقوم به ليس مفاجئا
لانه قام بهذا السلف اي مهاجمه القضاء
العهد
وتقديم نفسه على انه ضحيه هذا الشيء معهود
من ترامب شكرا لك
استاذه الحكومه والقانون الدستوري في
الجامعه الامريكيه احداثنا من فيرجينيا
في مزيد من الاخباريه عبر العالم التقى
وزير الخارجيه المصري سامح شكري نظيره
السوري فيصل للمقداد الذي يقوم بزياره الى
القاهره هي الاولى من نوعها لوزير خارجيه
سوري منذ 12 عاما وقالت الخارجيه المصريه
ان الوزيرين عقد لقاء ثنائيا مغلقا عقدته
جلسه مباحثات موسعه بين وفدي البلدين
تناولت مختلفه جوانب العلاقات الثنائيه
وسبل دفعها وتعزيزها
ارتفع عدد قتل الاعاصير التي ضربت ثلاث
ولايات وسط جنوب الولايات المتحده الى 21
شخصا على الاقل وتسببت العواصف ايضا
بانقطاع خدمه الكهرباء عن نحو 700 الف
منزل في ولايه انديانا
واركنسا وايلينو
وجورجيا وقال عمده مقاطعه
في ولايه تنيسيا سبعه اشخاص قتلوا في
المقاطعه التي تعتبر المنطقه الاكثر تضررا
بموجه العواصف الحاليه وسجلت الهيئه
الوطنيه للارصاد الجويه اكثر من 60 اعصارا
في ولايات متعدده يومي الجمعه والسبت
كما اظهر الصور ناشطين
اعصارين ضرباء مدينه كيوتا بولايه ايوا
الامريكيه حيث تتحرك جبهه عاصفه ضخمه نحو
شرقي البلاد
قالت وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه ان 10
طائرات صينيه عبرت خط المنتصف بمضيق
تايوان الذي يمثل حاجزا غير رسميا بين
الجانبين وقال انها ارسلت مقاتلات لتعذير
طائرات الصينيه كما فعلت الانظمه
الصاروخيه الدفاعيه وتتهم وزاره الدفاع
التايوانيه الصين بالقيام بتصرفات تتعمد
من خلالها اثاره التوتر وتقويض السلام
والاستقرار
[موسيقى]
الناخبون في فنلندا غدا باصواتهم في
انتخابات تشريعيه يتوقع ان تشهد منافسه
حاده بين مرشحي الاحزاب الرئيسيه في
البلاد وشهدت فنلندا اكبر تغييرات في
سياستها الخارجيه منذ عقود خلال الاشهر
الماضيه بسبب حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
ويعول الحزب الديمقراطي الاشتراكي على
شعبيه زعيمته سنمر وقيادتها للبلاد في
مسعا للحصول على عضويه حلف شمال الاطلسي
بينما تظهر استطلاعات الراي صعودا لاحزاب
اليمين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هؤلاء بعض صغار فنلندا التي صنفت انها
اسعد دوله في العالم ظلت كذلك ست سنوات
رغم الخوف الذي سببه لها غزو جارتها روسيا
لاوكرانيا خوف ربما بدا يتلاشى قليلا
بتاكيد انضمامها الوشيك الى حلف شمال
الاطلسي قبل ايام فقط من الانتخابات
العامه اولويه الامن امر يتفق عليه الجميع
رغم اختلافهم في قضايا اخرى كثيره
كل شخص في فنلندا تقريبا يعتقد اننا يجب
ان نكون جزءا من النيتو
تغيرنا كثيرا وبسرعه هذا العام السؤال
يدور بشان القضايا الداخليه مثل البيئه
والصحه والتعليم
من المهم جدا ان نظل ملتزمين بالاتحاد
الاوروبي واهداف التحول الى الطاقه
الخضراء لان هذه هي الامور التي يعرف بها
هذا البلد
في الانتخابات الفنلنديه كل صوت يفرط
فاستطلاعات الراي الاخيره تظهر فوارق
طفيفه تندرج في هامش الخطا بين الاحزاب
الرئيسيه الثلاثه تتشكل الحكومات
الفنلنديه في العقود الاخيره من ائتلافات
بين الاحزاب دون ان يتفرد احدها بالحكم
لكن توازنات القوى قد تسقط رئيسه الوزراء
الحالي
حتى لو كانت رئيسه الوزراء نجمه سياسيه
دوليه فهي لا تبدو كذلك في فنلندا وهناك
الكثير من التحديات التي تواجهها واهمها
الاقتصاديه بسبب الديون الكبيره التي
تكبدتها البلاد خلال حكمها طبعا بسبب وباء
كورونا والحرب في اوكرانيا
مثلت سانا مارين ظاهره سياسيه جديده في
فنلندا واوروبا تصف المناهضين للمهاجرين
بالعنصريين والمطالبين بالخروج من الاتحاد
الاوروبي بالاغبياء وتقول دون تردد ان
روسيا يجب ان تهزم في اوكرانيا هي سيده
صغيره تتحدث بلغه لم يعدها الناس في هذا
البلد من السياسيين
استقطبت سن مارين الاهتمام عندما اصبحت
اصغر رئيسه وزراء منتخبات في العالم قبل
اقل من ثلاث سنوات ونصف لكن هذه الفتره
شهدت تغييرات تاريخيه وجيو استراتيجيه
كبيره تجعل اعاده انتخابها اختبارا صعبا
سيمثل النجاح فيه رصيدا اضافيا لمسيرتها
السياسيه محمد المدهون الجزيره هيلسنكي
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا مجددا الى تعهد وزير الدفاع
الروسي بزياده امدادات الذخيره خلال زياره
القوات بلاده
باوكرانيا وهو تصريح ياتي بعد اتهامات من
ميليشيا بعدم توفير ذخيره كافيه للقوات
على خط المواجهه
وعده هذا ياتي بعد ايام من نسب صحيفه
نيورتنز الامريكيه الى معلومات
استخباراتيه ان روسيا ستشتري ذخائر
وملايين قذائف المدفعيه والصواريخ من
كوريا الشماليه ونقلت الصحيفه عن مسؤول
امريكي قوله ان المشتريات تشير الى ان
الجيش الروسي لا يزال يعاني نقصا حادا في
الامدادات باوكرانيا لاسباب منها قيود
الصادرات والعقوبات يقول مسؤولون غربيون
ان العقوبات الغربيه تحد من قدره روسيا
على استبدال المركبات والاسلحه التي دمرت
في اوكرانيا وفي وقت سابق من الحاليه كشفت
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه ان جنود الاحتياط
الروسي ربما يستخدمون مجاريث في القتال
اليدوي في اوكرانيا بسبب نقص الذخيره
ويقول محللون عسكريون انه على الرغم من
وجود نقص في الذخيره بالفعل الا ان الصوره
اكثر تعقيدا حيث لا تزال القوات الروسيه
تستخدم ضعف كميه الذخيره التي يستخدمها
الجانب الاوكراني
الحديث عن الذخائر وحاجه القوات على
الجبهات تقابل وتعذيرات مماثله من كياد من
نقص ذخيره المدفعيه والصواريخ قبل هجوم
الربيع المضاد الاوكراني ضد روسيا ولكن
الدعم قادم فقبل ساعات نقلت رويترز عن
ثلاثه مسؤولين امريكيين القول ان الولايات
المتحده ستعلن خلال الايام القادمه عن
حزمه مساعدات عسكريه جديده لاوكرانيا
بقيمه مليارين و600 مليون دولار من
المتوقع ان يكون على قائمه الاعداد
الامريكي سته انواع من الذخائر تتضمن
ذخائر الدبابات بالاضافه الى رادارات
للمراقبه الجويه وصواريخ مضاده للدبابات
وشاحنات لنقل الوقود ومن المقرر ايضا
ادراج ذخائر جويه دقيقه ومعدات جسور قد
تستخدمها اوكرانيا للهجوم على مواقع روسيه
وستشمل الحزمه الامريكيه المركبات انقاذ
لمساعده المعدات الثقيله المعطله مثل
الدبابات وقذائف اضافيه لمنظومه ناس سامز
للدفاع الجوي التي قدمتها الولايات
المتحده وحلفائها
وسبت ايضا طلبه اوكرانيا من بولندا 100
مدرعه متعدده المهام من طراز رسومات
تصنعها بترخيص من فنلندا بتمويل من
الاتحاد الاوروبي والولايات المتحده
للحديث عن هذا الموضوع معنى من بيروت
العميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك سيد الياس اذن نحن
نتحدث عن شحل الذخيره من الطرفين
الاوكرانيه والروسي لكن الى اي مدى برايك
هذا الواقع
سيجعل استاتيكو الميدان محتوما في
المستقبل القريب
حسن ان ياتي من وزير الدفاع ان هناك نقص
هذا امر مهم جدا يعني ياتي من اعلى سلطه
عسكريه في روسيا يعني هذه الحرب التي
تخوضها روسيا اليوم هي الحرب التقليديه
حسب العقيده القتاليه لروروسيه عبر
التاريخ الروسي ولكن في المرحله الاولى لم
يحسب لهكذا نوع من الحرب حرب ثابته حرب
استنزاف استهلك فيها في احد الايام حسن
اقتربت روسيه من استعمال 60 الف قذيفه
مدفعيه يوميا هي لم تحسب لهذا الحساب
والنقص هو في الجهتين وفي كل العتاد وهذا
الامر ياخذنا الى ما يسمى بالستيل ميت كما
قلت يعني مرحله الاستنزاف الجمود من هنا
التحضير لمرحله الحركيه من خلال المساعدات
التي تحدثت عنها قبل قليل
لكن الغريب ان شح الذخيره ليس للمره
الاولى التي يتم الحديث عنها لكن على
الرغم من ذلك القوات الروسيه حققت تقدما
يعني مهما كان حجم هذا التقدم لكنها عمليا
على الارض تفوقت على القوات الاوكرانيه
التي تصلها
معدات ودبابات وغير ذلك
الدبابات لم تصل حسن الى درجه متقدمه ولم
تنظم ضمن المنظومه اليوم عندما نلاحظ ما
يزيد او موازين القوى بين روسيا
واوكرانيا الميازين هي لصالح روسيه بالطبع
العديد العدد الذخيره وحتى الان قبل البدء
بكوريا الشماليه تعتمد روسيه على انتاجها
الخاص على سلاحها اما اوكرانيا فهي محكومه
بالمساعدات الغربيه وكل عمليه عسكريه كي
تنجح هي مرتبطه بمباشره بنوعيه السلاح
التي تاتي من الغرب بالطبع يعني يجب ان
ننظر ايضا حسن الى الخسائر في اي تقدم
يعني تسعه اشهر او تقارب على عشره اشهر
مدينه بخموت لا تزال صامده وهناك صراع بين
بريكوجين ممول شركه فاجنر ووزاره الدفاع
عن نفس الموضوع الا وهو النقص في العديد
والذخائر هذا الامر النقص في العديد
والذخائر لكن من الجهه او بالاحرى عند
الجهه الروسيه هل يمكن ان يكون حافزا
للقوات الاوكرانيه للتسريع بهجوم الربيع
المضاد هذا اذا
وصلتها الاسلحه اللازمه لذلك
بالطبع
الهجوم الاوكراني هو السبيل والنجاح شرط
النجاح هو السبيل للذهاب الى طاوله
مفاوضات اللهم الا حصل ما ليس في الحسبان
الانتقال الى المرحله النوويه هذا الامر
مستبعد حاليا بالطبع ولكن يبقى ليس
بالضروره حسن ان يكون هذا الهجوم في مكان
ما مركز كما يقال
قد يكون في عده اماكن وهذا ما تحدث عنه
انه قد يكون هناك عده هجومات عكسيه تحقق
فيها القوات الاوكرانيه نجاح وفي عده جهات
على سبيل المثال حتى في مخموت يعني وصلت
القوات الاوكرانيه الروسيه معجنه الى
الامتداد الاقصى والى الاستنزاف الاقصى
وهذا امر افضل وقت للقيام بهجوم عكسي ولكن
ليس قبل ان تجهز القوات الاوكرانيه
شكرا جزيلا لك العميد الياس حناء الخبيره
العسكري والاستراتيجي حدثنا من بيروت
[موسيقى]
سادت حاله من الدولار وبدا الناس يركضون
هكذا لخص مسؤول في شرطه الباكستانيه ما
حدث في مدينه كراتشي عندما توافدت نساء
محتاجات مع اطفالهن الى مصنع في الحي قرر
صاحبه توزيع تبرعات غذائيه ما بين 600 الى
700 شخص كانوا في المجمع الصناعي الصغير
ما الذي حدث تدافع تسبب بمصرع احد عشر
شخصا اكثرهم نساء واطفال هي ليست حديثه
التدافع الاولى المرتبطه بالحاجه الى
مساعدات غذائيه فقد تكررت مؤخرا في
باكستان الذي قفزت فيه الاسعار الى نسبه
قياسيه في مارس اذار الماضي
هو مشهد مؤلم يذكرنا بما يعاني منه اناس
كثر حول العالم ويعيد الى الصداره اهميه
قيمه التضامن مع المحتاجين خصوصا في هذه
الايام والامل كل الامل الا يضطر البعض
الى المغامره بحياته من اجل الحصول على
احتياجاته واحتياجات اطفاله الاساسيه دمتم
بخير والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]